cierra el periódico mas fragoroso y
popular de hong kong la directiva del
apple daily anunciaba hoy que este fin
de semana lanzará su última edición en
papel y apagará su página web la
decisión llegaba pocas horas después de
conocerse que había sido detenido su
jefe de editoriales por la autoría de
cinco artículos en los que se pedía la
adopción de sanciones internacionales
para hong kong esos artículos son según
la nueva ley de seguridad nacional
constitutivos del delito de colusión con
fuerzas extranjeras y había motivado la
detención en los últimos días de otros
cinco altos directivos del diario 'el
apple daily simboliza la división de la
sociedad con conesa para unos es un
paladín de la libertad para otros es un
tabloide infame el periódico
sensacionalista y sexista no ha sido
ajeno a los escándalos desde que naciera
20 años atrás por ejemplo con la
publicidad que asemejaba a los chinos
del interior con plagas de langostas que
asolaban hong kong también ha sido el
mayor defensor de las protestas de los
últimos años su desaparición en
cualquier caso es una terrible noticia
para la libertad de prensa